das ist sozusagen die befürchtung von
jedem hundebesitzer wenn man gassi geht
der hund geht kurz ins gebüsch
schnüffelt frist das sind manchmal
sekunden in denen dort etwas aufgenommen
wird von dem hund wie kann man das am
besten verhindern oder gibt es da aus
ihrer sicht überhaupt ein weg gehe zu
verhindern dass der hund etwas frisst
also es gibt natürlich in sicheren weg
das zu verhindern indem ich mein und
alleine lasse und in meinem
unmittelbaren einwirkungsbereich dann
sollten wir das als halter gelingen das
ist aber natürlich immer die zweitbeste
lösung weil wir natürlich als tierschutz
wir dafür sind dass hunde auch
entsprechend freilauf haben
das heißt die deutlich schönere lösung
aus meiner sicht ist natürlich hinunter
auf zu trainieren nicht unkontrolliert
draußen irgendwas aufzunehmen
das macht man natürlich am allerbesten
vom welpenalter an das ist natürlich ein
schlechter rat für alle leute die jetzt
schon dreijährigen grund haben aber auch
dreijährige runde wie 30-jährige
menschen auch können noch dazulernen
das heißt auch das kann ich mit meinem
hund üben mir ist gleichwohl bewusst
dass das nicht einfach als ich besitze
selber ein labrador und der funktioniert
auch als staubsauger draußen das heißt
das ist keine leichte aufgabe spricht
sich leicht in der kamera ist aber
tatsächlich ein tägliche aufgabe also
bei unserem familienhund kann ich mir
das auch nicht so richtig vorstellen
dass man sie dahin trainieren kann aber
es ist ja zumindest schon mal ein
wichtiger punkt dass es theoretisch
möglich ist und dann müsste man
tatsächlich da tatsächlich viel zeit und
energie rein investieren jetzt kommen
wir mal zu wenn mein hund draußen was
findet und triumphierend als labrador da
an bringt dann kann ich natürlich
versuchen eine bord tisch zu machen das
heißt ich gebe ihm ein leckerchen
und er gibt mir das was immer eklig ist
er da draußen gefunden hat also das ist
ein thema von hundetrainer mehr als von
tierarzt aber da gibt es natürlich schon
auch mittel und wege das zu tun dass
regelmäßig zu trainieren vernünftig der
bands dann passiert ist wenn der
und dann mutmaßlich gift aufgenommen hat
was sind die ersten symptome auf welche
muss sich da genau achten um dann
reagieren zu können
also schon etwas jetzt hier in rede
steht ist das ja praktischen stoff der
so ähnlich funktioniert im körper wie
zucker wie glucose aber eben keine ist
in dem sinne
das heißt der körper denkt oh hoppla da
kommt eine riesenmenge wir haben jetzt
plötzlich eine riesenmenge glukose im
blut der blutzucker geht sie hoch denkt
der körper spendet entsprechend viel
insulin das der bauchspeicheldrüse um
diesen vermeintlichen zuckerspiegel
wegzukriegen
und in wirklichkeit ist der
blutzuckerspiegel ganz normal gewesen
es wird eine riesenmenge insulin
ausgeschüttet und der blutzucker bricht
total zusammen und den rest der rest
folgt dann daraus das kennt jeder denke
ich fast jeder mensch war aus eigener
erfahrung wenn der blutzucker total
runter geht wenn man unter zu gott dann
wird einem schwabbelig in den beiden man
kriegt weiche knie buchstäblich die
muskulatur arbeitet nicht mehr richtig
weil quasi der treibstoff ausgeht
und irgendwann geht dann oben die lampe
aus den zentralrechner man wird
ohnmächtig am boden legen oder viel
herum und der mechanismus ist beim und
exakt dieser der beschriebene aber
daraus folgt dann auch schon gleich was
sie mich ruhig als nächstes fragen
nämlich was kann ich als halter tun in
der situation wenn ich wenn ich sicher
bin dass es sich um sexy lied handelt
weil ich das lebensmittel sicherstellen
konnte also das kaugummi packung oder
die bombe packung was war dann ist
ergibt sich aus dem beschriebenen
mechanismus das gegenmittel das heißt
ich gebe zu dass das hauptproblem in der
akku situation ist da abschieden musiker
zusammen bericht und deswegen gebe ich
dann einfach zucker oder honig dem hund